théâtre maintenant avec du Victor Hugo à
la Comédie Française l'événement est
plutôt rare aujourd'hui ces pièces ne
sont plus beaucoup jouer pour l'occasion
on a repris un texte qui avait fait
scandale en son temps la pièce
s'intitule Le Roi s'amuse une charge
contre les puissants et les intrigue de
cours une pièce écrite aussi par un
homme qui avait été exilé par les
princes reportage Dominique Ponet et
Robin
tboule voici la sagesse ma chère aimons
et jouissons et faisons bonne
chair un souverain Paillard doublé d'un
libertin dans le roi samamuse il s'agit
de François 1 mais à la création de la
pièce en 1832 le public vit une
caricature de Louis Philippe et au
lendemain de sa création la pièce fut
interdite cette uvre destin malheureux
la voici remontée par Jean-Luc bouté si
elle a évidemment perdu de sa charge
politique elle est restée insolente par
son langage
mêmeureuse c'estous nous sommes la
France un peuple entier 15 millions
d'hommes richesse honneur plaisir
pouvoir chois tout est pour moi tout est
à moi je suis le roi la langue de Victor
Hugo elle est très forte il faut la
mordre vraiment il faut faut y aller à
fond il faut il on peut pas jouer ça à
moitié c'est le
romantisme dur cru qui va au bout de de
ses émotions c'est des personnages
fousan je le
roi les rois ont souvent des bouffons
chez Hugo il s'appelle Triboulet c'est
une sorte de méchant Casimodo qui est
interprété ici avec une vraie jubilation
par Roland
Bertin ch enfant ma
cité mon pays ma famille mon épouse ma
mère et ma sœur et ma fille mon bonheur
ma richesse et mon culte et ma loi mon
univers c'est
toi toujours toi il y a il y a des
exagérations quelquefois même une sorte
de vulgarité de ton comme ça mais c'est
une pièce géniale dans dans son son
imaginaire et et où elle nous transporte
c'est comme une sorte de compte de
compte de fée
noir rire méchanceté mystification
rebondissement et bien sûr drame il y a
tout cela dans cette pièce excessive J
avec une vraie loyauté par une troupe
qui visiblement s'amuse